Hey, Jen.
Hi.
What are we doing today ?
Basic LA stuff.
We're going on a hike.
Well, it's hot .
Why are you walking so fast?
So we can get it done.
I'm walking at the speed of my legs, which is slow.
Doggy!
Guys, Jenna keeps calling me Yunobo.
*whistles*
Well that was a great hike.
We had a very successful hike, but now we're heading to get some peanut butter cookies for Jordan.
He's about to hit 10 million subscribers on YouTube so to celebrate, we're getting him his favorite cookies.
We're also gonna get him a little cake I think. Maybe it'll say happy 10 mil?
There's little hot dogs and stuff. Look at this watermelon cheesburger cake. I love this place
Ten.
There's no zero.
Oh, no sparkler candles. We could just break it off that?
We could.
I'm sorry, I overheard, They're hiding behind the 9's.
Oh, that's so good! Thank you!
Yes, look, we don't have to break up the six.
Jordan's going to have the best not birthday party celebration.
Okay, I'll now go change real quick cause I'm sweaty, and then I'm gonna, I'm gonna, I'm gonna, I don't know.
I'm gonna go to the third Street
and I'm gonna go get a nice little light glaze on my hair
because I always wait until the last minute to make hair appointments,
And she can never take me so usually I'll just go in and get a nice little glaze to make it a little bit darker
and that can hold me off until I can actually make an appointment.
Hey Doggy
I love you. Do you know that it's almost your 2-year adoption date when we adopted you.
*boop*
Don't boop him!
Off again!
Great job.
Riveting.
You gotta get the b-Roll Jenna, gotta get the b-roll.
It's not a b-roll if there's audio.
This isn't a b-roll, this is a-roll.
Time to get this hair fixed.
Great time to go. I'm gonna bring some games. I really wanted to bring this game but here's the problem.
Jenna, do you know what the problem is with this game?
Copyright.
These boys weren't even, uhh, they're barley born in 19...
Yeah, Matt was born in what, 90...
2!
I guess Jordan was as well right
Matt said like 40 minutes ago that he was going to be here in 10 minutes and now
It's 40 minutes later, and he said he's going to be 11 minutes.
See, he said 10 minutes
at 6:21
It's 6:42
Hey, whats up guys?
Did you have a good day today?
Yeah I had a great day.
I was having a good day till I got in the car.
What time did that start?
We've been torturing him.
Me and George were having such a good day and then two women entered the car and... look what happened.
Yeah, if you weren't a liar, full of lies.
Okay, Jordan we got you a present.
Yo, as if this day couldn't get any better.
But you should put Sparklers on it.
What?
Sparklers.
Ooohhhhh! Hold on!
Wow!
Yes!
Are those sparklers?
I kept respelling Sparklez. She's like "is that even a Z?"
Wait, show them, show them the best part.
What's the best part?
Cookies.
Wait a minute, there's more.
I didn't have them at the last party I had and I felt so bad about it.
They're unbelievable. I'm gonna, I'm gonna have one right now on camera.
Oh god, it's so much bigger than I remember it.
It's like a nutter butter cookie if that makes sense
*Whispers* I've never had nutter butter.
*gasps*  Never had nutter butter.
It is so good cause they said they changed the recipe.
Oh,it's good.
Phew
Well, what is this
It is... an Aston Martin DB 11.
BB! BB-8!
D, D as in dog.
Is it like a gray?
It's like it's a white. I don't know the exact...
I love the white. It's a good white. It's like a pearl.
Did you get this wrap too?
Man, is that new since last time as well.
I think so.
This is a four seater?
We took Uber here.
Matty is not allowed to sit in front seats, it's dangerous
Is that really a thing?
Yes because he can get it by the airbag and die.
This is true. I like your windshield wiper.
It's pretty cool. Its the, it's definitely the show stopper
So apparently this game of life is not made for more than 4 players. So this is my gamepiece
I said you could have it.
I read online, it said 2-8 players
Well this one isn't. We're probably going to run into problems
The worlds full of problems anyway.
Well Trump's president so...
Which rapper released the song "It was a good day" in 1993?
Ice Cube.
I knew you would know it so good job.
I didn't either but I knew you would
Jay Z's "Hard Knock Life" ghetto anthem samples a song from which musical?
Annie
Come on, everyone knew that
I am so upset with this game.
Justine no, stop vlogging.
Nobody told me we were vlogging, let me vlog.
You don't vlog anymore. You're a streamer.
Oh, you're a streamer now.
I've been a streamer for 3 days. Give me a break.
What if I move in?
Give me this camera
This is all the money I have
This is real life. I'm literally just getting bypassed
Okay, is it my turn now?
Yeah, I've got no debt now.
Happy 10 million subs. What are you gonna do.
Oh we should eat cake
I'm gonna get, oh, we should finish the game of life.
But that's what we're gonna do to celebrate.
Matt's an actual hog. Like he is an actual hog
I get money! From who?
Matt give me $20,000 because I have a college degree as a scientist
So do I spin?
I have no house, no kids, no husband, I'm just sitting here alone with all my money.
That's not tap. That's heel.
Okay, so you're going to tap dance with the alchohol
Are you shuffling?
Are you guys together now?
Power couple
We gotta make a fire.
I got it.
Now you see how people really mess themselves up with sparklers.
That's a good. That's great. What does eska ttt mean
What does eska ttt mean
Little pump
Well this was a great vlog. I'll see you guys tomorrow. Bye